[Music]
for 50 years
they lay under glass in the dickerson
museum
and they were labeled the medici boots
they were fashioned of creamy leather
pliable as a young girl's hands they
were threaded with silver
applicated with sapphire silks and
scarlet and set on the tip of each was a
pale and lovely amethyst
such were the medici boots old silas
dickerson
globetrotter and collector had brought
the boots from a dusty shop in florence
when he was a young man filled with the
lust for travel and adventure
the years passed and silas dickerson was
an old man
his hair white his eyes dim his veined
hands trembling with the egg you that
precedes death
when he was 90 and the years of his
wanderings over silas dickerson died one
morning as he sat in a high-backed
venetian chair in his private museum
the 14th century gold leaf paintings the
japanese processional banners
the stolen bones of a normandy saint all
the beloved trophies of his travels must
have watched the dead man
impassively for hours before his
housekeeper found him
the old man sat with his head thrown
back against the faded tapestry of the
venetian chair
his eyes closed his bony arms extended
along the beautifully carved arms of the
chair
and on his lap lay the medici boots
it was high noon when they found him and
the sun was streaming through the
stained glass window above the chair
and picking at the amethyst so that the
violet stone seemed to eye marta the old
housekeeper with an impudent glitter
marta muttered a prayer and crossed
herself before she ran like a scared
rabbit with the news of the master's
death
silas dickerson's only surviving
relatives the three young delameters
did not take too seriously the note
which was found among the papers in the
museum's desk
old silas had written the note it was
addressed to john delameter for john was
his uncle's favorite
but john's pretty wife suzanne and his
twin brother dr
eric read it over his shoulder and they
all smiled tolerantly
old dickerson had written of things
incomprehensible to the young moderns
the contents of my private museum are
yours john to do with as you see fit
merely as a suggestion i would say that
the anaquarian society would snap
up many of the things a very few are of
no particular value
except to me one thing i want done
however
the medici boots of ivory leather must
either be destroyed
or be put forever under glass in a
public museum
i prefer that they be destroyed for they
are a dangerous possession
they have gone to the adulterous
rendezvous celebrated in the scandalous
verses of lorenzo the magnificent
they have shot the feet of a murderess
they were cursed by the church as
trappings of the devil
inciting the wearer to foul deeds in
intrigue
i shall not disturb you with all their
hideous history but i repeat
they are a dangerous possession i have
taken care to keep them under lock and
key
behind plate glass for more than 50
years
i have never taken them out destroy the
medici boots before they destroy you
but he did take them out cried suzanne
uncle was holding the boots when
when marta found him there in the museum
john re-read the note and looked
thoughtfully at his young wife
yes perhaps he was preparing to destroy
them right then
of course i think the poor old fellow
took things a bit too seriously
he was very old you know and marta says
he practically lived in this museum of
his
and why call a pair of old boots
dangerous of course we all know the
medicis were plenty dangerous
but the medici boots that's ridiculous
john
besides suzanne paused provocatively her
red lips pouting
she looked down at her trimly shod feet
besides i'd like to try on those medici
boots just once
they're lovely i think john was frowning
thoughtfully
he scarcely heard her suggestion he
spoke to eric instead
and his voice seemed a bit troubled i
believe that uncle was getting ready to
destroy those boots that very morning he
died
else why should he have taken them from
their case after 50 years
yes i believe you're right john because
that note is dated fully a month before
uncle's death
i think he brooded over leaving those
boots to one he cared for
poor old man i wouldn't call him so eric
he had his dreams of adventure realized
more fully than most men
i think i'll do as he says i'll destroy
the medici boots
if he'd feel better about it ascended
his brother but suzanne did not speak
she was looking at her shoe pursing her
lips thoughtfully
seeing her feet encased in the gay
embroideries of the medici boots
john seemed relieved by his decision yes
i'd better do it
we'll be getting back to town in a few
days old erskine you know
uncle's lawyer is coming down this
afternoon then soon we'll be on the wing
suzy and i vienna paris the alps thanks
to uncle
maybe you think i'm not thankful for my
chance at a bit more work at johns
hopkins
said eric and they did not again speak
of the medici boots
the deaf old lawyer of the dickerson
estate arrived and suzanne with the easy
capability that was part of her charm
saw that he was made comfortable at
seven there was a perfect dinner
served on the awning terrace outside the
softly lit living room
the stars aided the two little rosy
lamps on the table
and swaying willows beside a stone
encircled pool swung the incense of the
garden
about them as dinner ended john took
from the pocket of his coat a small
limp leather book he pushed back his
dessert plate and laid the book on the
table
tapping it with a finger as he spoke
this is the history of the medici boots
it was in a little wall safe in the
museum after all uncle said of the
medici boots shall we read it
and turning to the old lawyer he told of
silas dickerson's letter concerning the
boots
erskine shook his head smiling most
collectors get an exaggerated sense of
the supernatural
read this by all means it should prove
interesting
yes read it john suzanne and eric spoke
almost together
so in the circle of rosy light at their
little table john read the story of the
medici boots
it was not a long story and it was told
in the language of an anonymous
translator
but as john read on his listeners were
drawn together as by a spell
they scarcely breathed and the summer
night that was so mildly beautiful
seemed to take on a sense of hovering
danger
in the palace of giuliano de medici i
have lived long
i am an old woman now as the years are
reckoned in this infamous place
though i am but fifty and three
separated from my betrothed
duped sold into the marble labyrinth of
this hateful place
it was long before my spirit broke and i
went forth bejeweled and attired in
elegance
among the silk clad florentines i was
labeled the most beautiful mistress of
any of the medici
i was smirked at fond upon for my lord's
favors
obscenely jested about in the orgies
that took place in the great banquet
hall of the palace
but in my heart always lay the
remembrance of my lost love
and in my soul grew black hatred for the
medici and all their kind
i who had dreamed only of a modest home
a kind husband
black-haired trusting little children
was made a tool of the medici infamy
in time i almost felt myself in league
with the devil
secretly and with a growing sense of
elation i made frequent rendezvous with
a foul hag
whose very name was anathema to the
churchly folk of florence
in her whole of a room in a certain
noisome street
she imparted to me those terrible
secrets of the black arts which were
deep in her soul
it was amusing that she was paid in
medici gold
the corruption of the medici bred in
them fear in me
is sort of reckless bravery it was i who
poisoned the wine of many a foe of the
medici
it was i who put the point of a dagger
in the heart of the old prince de
vittorio
whose lands and power and palaces were
coveted by my lord giuliano
after a time bloodshed became an
exhilaration to me
the death agonies of those who drank the
poison cup became more interesting than
the flattery of the medici followers
even the ladies of the house of the
medici did me the honor of their subtly
barbed friendliness
through this very friendliness i
conceived my plan of sweet revenge upon
the monsters who had ruined my life
with so great a hatred boiling in my
soul that my mind reeled
my senses throbbed my heart rose in my
throat like a spurt of flame
i cursed three things of exquisite
beauty with all the fervor of my newly
learned lessons in devilish lore
these three beautiful objects i
presented to three ladies of the house
of medici
presented them with honeyed words of
mock humility
a necklace of jeweled links i pledge
myself to the devil and willed that the
golden necklace would tighten
on the soft throat of the lady of the
medici while she slept
and strangled her into black death a
bracelet of filigree and sapphires
to pierce by its hidden silver needle
the blue vein in a white medici wrist
so that her life's blood would spurt and
she would know the terror that the house
of the medici gave to others
last and most ingenious a pair of creamy
boots
pliable embroidered in silver and silks
encrusted with amethysts
my betrothal jewels in my hatred i
cursed the boots willing that the wearer
as long as a shred of the boots remained
should kill as i had killed
poison as i had poisoned leave all
thoughts of home and husband and live in
wantonness and evil
so i cursed the beautiful boots
forgetting in my hate
that perhaps another than a medici might
in the years to come
wear them and become the devil's pawn
even as i am now
in my life the medici will have the
boots of that i feel sure
but after that i can only hope that this
bloody history of the boots may be found
when i am no more
and may it be a warning i have lived to
see my gifts received and worn and i
have laughed in my soul to see my curses
bring death and terror and evil to three
medici women
i know not what will become of the
golden necklace the bracelet or the
boots
the boots may be lost or stolen or they
may lie in a medici palace for age on
age
but the curse will cling to them till
they are destroyed
so i pray that no woman ceba medici will
ever wear them
as i live and breathe and do the bidding
of the lords of florence the accursed
medici
i have told the truth when i am dead
perhaps they will find this book
and in hell i shall know and be glad
maria modena de cavori florence 1476
phew said old erskine john laughed
i don't suppose this charming history
would have been any more thrilling if i
had read it from the original book
in italian of course wonder where uncle
got it
there was no mention of it being in the
library but there it was
now will you destroy those boots asked
eric and he was not entirely in jest
but suzanne said laughingly not before i
find out if the medici lady had a
smaller foot than i
are they still in the museum john never
you mind my dear they're not for the
likes of you
oh don't be silly john this is 1955 not
the 15th century
and they laughed at suzanne's
earnestness the book that held the story
of the medici boots lay on the white
cloth
looking like a book of lovely verse
suzanne
a small white blur against the summer
dark sat quietly while the men talked of
silas dickerson
his life his mania for collecting his
death that had so fittingly come to him
in his museum
it was nearly 12 when suzanne left the
men on the terrace and with a quiet good
night entered the living room and
crossed to the long shining stairs
the men went on with their talk once
john
looking toward the jutting wing that was
the museum exclaimed
look at that will you i swear i saw a
light in the museum
you locked it didn't you asked eric of
course the keys in my desk upstairs
hmm i'm probably mistaken but it did
seem as though a light shone there just
a moment ago
reflection from the living room window i
think country life is making you jittery
jon
and eric laughed at his brother the men
sat
on reluctant to leave the beauty of the
night and it was almost two o'clock when
they finally went inside
john said i think i'll not disturb
suzanne and he went to sleep in a wide
four-poster bed in a room next to his
wife
eric and the old lawyer were in rooms
across the hall
the still summer night closed about the
house of silas dickerson
and when the moon lay dying against the
bank of cloud puffed across the sky by
the little wind that came before dawn
young dr eric delameter awoke
suddenly and completely to a feeling of
clammy apprehension
he had not locked his door and now
across the greatness of the room he saw
it slowly opening
a hand was closed around the edge of the
door a woman's hand
small and white and jeweled eric sat
straight and tense on the edge of his
bed
peering across the room a woman young
and slender
in a long trailing gown came toward him
smiling
it was suzanne with a gasp eric watched
her approach till she stood directly
before him
suzanne you're asleep shall i call john
he thought that perhaps he should not
waken her there were things one must
remember about sleepwalkers but
physicians scarcely believed them
eric was puzzled too by her costume it
was not a night robe she wore
but an elaborate trailing dress upon
which embroideries and silver shone
faintly
her short black curls were bound about
three times with strands of pearly beads
her slim white arms were loaded with
bracelets
the pointed toes of little shoes peeped
beneath her gown
little shoes of creamy leather an
amethyst gleamed on each toe
the sight of these amethyst tips
affected eric strangely
much as though he thought he had looked
at something hideously repulsive
he stood up and put out a hand to touch
suzanne's arm
suzanne he said gently let me take you
to john
shall i suzanne looked up at him and her
brown eyes
usually so mary were deeply slumberous
not with sleep but with a look of utter
abandon
she shook her pearl-bound head slowly
smilingly
no not john i want you eric
mad suzanne must be mad was eric's quick
thought
but her caress was swifter than his
thought both jewel laid in arms about
his neck
suzanne kissed him her red lips pouting
warmly upon his
suzanne you don't know what you're doing
he grasped both her hands in his and
with a haste that would have seemed
ludicrous to him had he viewed the scene
in a picture play
he hurried her out of his room and
across the hall
eric opened her door softly and with no
gentle hand shoved suzanne inside her
room
she seemed like a little animal in his
grasp she hissed at him
clawed and scratched at his hand but
when he had shut the door
she did not open it again and after a
moment he went back to his own room
his mouth set in a firm line his heart
beating fast
eric locked his door with a noiseless
turn of the key
it was almost dawn and the garden lay
like a rare pastel outside his window
but eric saw none of it he scarcely
thought though his lips moved
as if chaotic words were struggling for
utterance
he looked down at his hand where two
long red scratches oozed a trickle of
blood
after he had washed his hand he laid
down on his bed and covered his eyes
with his arm
against the picture of suzanne above all
else there stood out the gleaming tips
of her little shoes
as he had glimpsed them through the dim
light of his room when she came toward
him
she wore the medici boots suzanne must
have taken them from the museum
eric rather dreaded breakfast but when
he came down at eight to the terrace
where a rustic table was said invitingly
he found john and the lawyer awaiting
him jon greeted his brother
affectionately
morning old boy hope you slept well why
so solemn
feeling seedy no no i'm perfectly all
right
eric replied hastily relieved that
suzanne was not present
he added with a scarcely noticeable
hesitation suzanne not coming down
no replied john easily she seemed to
want to sleep a while
send her regrets she'll see us at lunch
jon went on i certainly had a nightmare
last night thought a woman in a
long-shining dress came into my room and
tried to stab me
this morning i found that a glass on my
bed table was overturned and broken
and by george i'd cut my wrist on it he
showed a jagged cut on his wrist
take a look dr eric eric looked at the
cut carefully
not bad but you might have bled to death
had it been a quarter of an inch to the
left
if you like i'll fix it up a bit for you
after breakfast
eric's voice was calm enough but his
pulse was pounding his heart sick
all morning he rode through the
countryside adjoining the dickerson
estate
but he let the mare go as she liked and
where she liked for his mind was busy
with the events of the hour before dawn
he knew that the slash on his brother's
wrist was made by steel not glass
yet when the ride was over he could not
bring himself to tell jon of suzanne's
visit
she must have been sleepwalking though i
can't account for the way she was decked
out
i've always thought suzanne extremely
modest in her dress certainly not
inclined to load herself with jewelry
and those boots john must get them today
and destroy them as he said
silly perhaps but his thoughts went on
and on
always returning to the medici boots in
spite of himself
eric came back from his ride at 11
o'clock with his troubled mind as when
he began it
he almost feared to see susanne at lunch
when he did meet her with john and mr
erskine on the cool shaded porch where
they lunched
he saw there was nothing to fear the
amorous clinging woman of the hour
before dawn was not there at all
there was only the suzanne whom eric
knew and loved as a sister
here again was their merry little
suzanne somewhat spoiled by her husband
it is true
but as suzanne sweetly feminine almost
childish in a crisp white frock
and little low-heeled sandals their talk
was lazily pleasant
of tennis honors and horses of the
prized delphiniums in the garden
of the tiny maltese kitten which suzanne
had brought up from the stables late
that morning
and installed in a pink bowed basket on
the porch
she showed the kitten to eric handling
its tiny paws gently
hushing its plaintive muse with
ridiculous pet names
perhaps i'm a bigger fool than i know
perhaps it never happened except in a
dream
eric told himself unhappily and yet
he looked at the red marks on his hand
marks made by a furious suzanne in that
hour before the dawn
he also remembered the cut on john's
wrist the cut so near the vein
eric declined john's invitation to go
through the museum with him that
afternoon
but he said with a queer sense of
diffidence while you're there john you'd
better get rid of the medici boots
creepy things to have around i think
they'll be destroyed all right
but suzanne is just bound to try them on
i'll get them though and do as uncle
said
eric remained on the terrace speculating
somewhat on just what john and suzanne
would do
now that the huge fortune of silas
dickerson was theirs
eric was not envious of his brother's
good luck and he was thankful for his
share in old silas generosity
at five o'clock he entered the hall just
as suzanne hurried in from the kitchen
she spread out her hands laughingly with
my own fair hands i've made individual
almond tortonis for dessert
cook thinks i'm a wonder each
masterpiece in a fluted silver dish
silver candy sprinkled on the pink
whipped cream
she made big eyes in mock gluttony eric
forgot for a moment that there had ever
been another suzanne
you're nothing but a little girl susie
you with your rhapsodies over pink
whipped cream
but it's sweet of you to go to such
trouble on a warm afternoon
see you in the whatever you call them at
dinner they're tortoni's eric
tortonis suzanne ran lightly up the
stairs
eric followed more slowly he entered his
room thinking that there were some
things which must be explained in this
house with the old museum
20 minutes before dinner eric and john
were on the terrace waiting for suzanne
john was talkative which was just as
well as he might have wondered at his
brother's silence
eric was torn between a desire to tell
his brother his reluctant suspicions
concerning the medici boots in suzanne
and his inclination to leave things
alone till the boots could be destroyed
he said differently jon does suzanne
have those
those boots john chuckled why yes i saw
them in a room
do you know she went down to the museum
last night and took those boots
it was a light i saw in the museum it
was her light suzanne has ideas
wants to wear the boots just once she
says to lay the ghost of this what's her
name
maria medena suzanne says she couldn't
sleep much last night
got up early and tried on those boots
well i think i'll destroy him tomorrow
uncle's wish so i'll do it tried them on
did she
well if you should ask me i'd say that
history of the boots was a bit too
exciting for suzanne it was a haunting
story
uncle must have swallowed it hook line
and sinker a of course
his letter showed that but suzanne lives
in the present not the past as uncle did
i suppose suzanne will wear those boots
or she won't feel satisfied
i don't exactly like the idea i must
confess
something like an electric shock passed
through eric he said somewhat
breathlessly
i don't think suzanne ought to have them
energy boots
jon looked at him curiously and laughed
i never knew you were superstitious eric
but do you really think i don't know
what i think john
but if she were my wife i'd take those
boots away from her uncle may have known
what he was talking about
well i think she's intending to wear
them at dinner so prepare to be dazzled
here she is now greeting sweetheart
suzanne swept across the terrace
her gown goldly shimmering pearls bound
about her head
as eric had seen her in the dim hour
before dawn
again the rosa bracelets were waiting
her slim arms
and she wore the medici boots the
amethyst tips peeping beneath her
shining dress
john ever ready for gay clowning arose
and bowed low
hail empress aha the dress you got in
florence on our honeymoon isn't it
and those darned medici boots suzanne
unsmilingly extended her hand for him to
kiss
john arched an eyebrow comically what's
the matter honey
going regal on me and retaining her hand
he kissed each of her fingers
suzanne snatched away her hand and the
glance she gave her husband was one of
venomous haughtiness
to eric she turned a look that was an
open caress leaning toward him
putting a hand on his arm as he stood
beside his chair
stern lipped with eyes that would not
look at john's hurt bewilderment
the three sat down then in the low
wicker chairs and waited for dinner
three people with oddly different
emotions john was hurt
slightly impatient with his bride eric
was furious with suzanne
though there was in his heart the almost
certain knowledge that the suzanne
beside them on the terrace
was not the susan they knew but a
cruelly strange woman
the product of a sinister force unknown
and compelling
no one looking on suzanne's red-lipped
and heavy-litted beauty
could miss the knowledge that here was a
woman dangerously subtle
carrying a power more devastating than
the darting lightning that now and then
showed itself over the treetops of the
garden eric began to feel something of
this
and there shaped in his mind a weariness
a defense against this woman who was not
suzanne
no alfresco dining tonight said john as
the darkening sky was veined by a sudden
spray of
green light rain on the way pretty good
storm i'd say
i like it replied suzanne drawing in a
deep breath of the sultry air
john laughed since when sweetheart you
usually shake and shiver through a
thunderstorm
suzanne ignored him she smiled at eric
and said in a low tone
and if i should lose my bravery you
would take care of me wouldn't you eric
before eric could reply dinner was
announced and he felt a relief
and also a dread this dinner was going
to be difficult
jon offered his arm to his wife smiling
at her hoping for a smile in return
but suzanne shrugged and said in a
caressing voice
eric eric could only bow stiffly and
offer his arm
while john walked slowly beside them his
face thoughtful
his gay spirits gone during dinner
however he tried to revive the lagging
conversation
suzanne spoke in a staccato voice and
her choice of words seemed strange to
eric
almost as though she were translating
her own thoughts from a foreign tongue
and finally suzanne's promised dessert
came cool and tempting in its silver
dishes
eric saw a chance to make the talk more
natural he said gaily
johnny your wife's a chef a famous
pastry chef
behold the work of her hands what did
you say it was suzanne
this oh i don't know what it's called
but this afternoon as you were leaving
the kitchen didn't you say it was almond
something or other
she shook her head smiling perhaps it is
i wouldn't know
the maid had placed the tray with the
three silver dishes of dessert before
suzanne
that she might put on them the final
sprinkling of delicate silver candies
daintily suzanne sifted the shining
bubbles over the fluff of cream
eric watching her felt very little
surprise when he saw suzanne
with almost ledger domain deafness sift
upon one dish a film of pinkish powder
which could not be detected after it lay
on the pink cream
waiting he knew not for what moment he
watched suzanne pass the silver dishes
herself
saw her offer the one with the powdered
top to john
and it was then that their attention was
attracted by the entrance of the maltese
kitten
so tiny it was so brave in its careening
totter across the shiny floor
small tail hoisted like a sail that john
and eric laughed aloud
suzanne merely glanced down at the
little creature and turned away
the kitten however came to her chair put
up a tiny paw
and caught its curved claws in the
fragile stuff of suzanne's gown
instantly her face became distorted with
rage and she kicked out at the kitten
savagely and with set lips it seemed to
eric that the amethysts on the medici
boots winked wickedly in the light of
the big chandelier
the kitten was flung some 10 feet away
and lay in a small panting heap
jon sprang up suzanne how could you
he took the kitten in his arms and
soothed it why
it's hearts beating like a trip hammer
he said i don't understand suzanne
as the kitten grew quiet he took a large
rose leaf from the table flowers and
spread it with a heaping spoonful of the
pink cream from his dessert
then he put the kitten on the floor
beside it here little one
lick this up it's fancy eating suzanne's
sorry i know she is
the kitten with the greed of its kind
devoured the cream covering its small
nose and whiskers with a pinkish film
suzanne sat back in her chair fingering
her bracelets
her eyes on eric's face john watched the
kitten and eric watched too
watch tensely for he sensed what would
happen to it
the kitten finished the cream licked its
paws and whiskers and turned to walk
away
then it spun around in a frantic
convulsion and in a moment lay dead on
its back
its tiny red tongue protruding its paws
rigid
outside the storm glowered and in the
chartreuse light of the forked lightning
the great chandelier was turned to a
sickly radiance
thunder rolled like muffled drums
suddenly suzanne began to laugh
peel after peel of terrible laughter and
then after a glare of lightning the big
chandelier winked out
the room was plunged into stormy
darkness and they could hear the rain
lashing through the garden to hurl
itself against the windows
don't be frightened suzanne it was
john's solicitous voice
and it was followed by a quick movement
from suzanne's side of the table
a sheet of blue-green light illuminated
the room for an instant
and eric saw suzanne struggling in her
husband's arms
one jeweled arm uplifted and in her hand
a shining dagger
with a bound that was almost involuntary
eric reached them
and struck at the knife in suzanne's
hand it clattered to the floor
and as though the fury of the storm and
suzanne's madness both were spent
the slashing rain and the lightning
stopped abruptly and suzanne ceased to
struggle
light the candles eric quickly on the
mantle to your right
susanna's hurt in the candlelight paley
golden and swaying
eric saw suzanne slumped limpy in john's
arms
the hem of her golden dress was readily
wet and one cream-colored little shoe
was fast becoming soaked with blood from
a slash across the instep
let's get her over to the window seat
eric do something for her
oh sweetheart don't moan like that there
was no question or reproach in john's
voice only compassion
eric took off his coat rolled up his
sleeves his mouth was grimly set his
hands steady
his voice crisply professional take off
those shoes john
she'll be herself then i mean that
she'll be suzanne
not a murderous of the medicis take them
off john they're at the bottom of this
you mean john's voice was breathless his
lips trembling
i mean those hellish boots have changed
suzanne from a sweet and lovely girl too
well do as i tell you i'll be back with
gauze and some things i need
when eric hurried back there were three
servants grouped at the dining room door
he spoke to them brusquely and they left
wide-eyed and whispering eric closed the
door
while the wet leaves tapped against the
windows and stars struggled through the
clouds
eric worked silently expertly grimly
by the light of a flashlight held in
john's unsteady hands
and the light of the flickering candles
the house lights were all snuffed out by
the storm
there eric gave a satisfied grunt
the brothers stood looking at suzanne
who seemed to sleep
her golden dress glimmered in the
candlelight and the pearls were slipping
from her dark hair
the medici boots lay in a limp and
bloody heap in the corner where eric had
flung them
when she awakes i shouldn't tell her
about any of this if i were you john
there are things you haven't told me
eric aren't there things about the
medici boots
eric looked steadily at his brother yes
old fellow and after i've told you those
boots must be destroyed
we'll burn them before this night is
over we mustn't move for now
we'll go out on the terrace it's wet
there but the air is fresh
did you smell something peculiar four as
they passed the corner where the medici
boots lay slashed and bloody
eric could have sworn that there came to
him a horrid odor fetid
hotly offensive the odor of iniquity and
ancient bloody death
as i entered john kiriwan's study i was
too much engrossed in my own thoughts to
notice at first
the haggard appearance of his visitor a
big handsome young fellow
well known to me hello kiriwan i greeted
hello gordon
haven't seen you for a while how's
evelyn and before he could answer
still on the crest of the enthusiasm
which had brought me here i exclaimed
look here you fellows i've got something
that will make you stare i got it from
that robber
ahmed mekhtub and i paid high for it but
it's worth it look
from under my code i drew the jewel
hilted afghan dagger which had
fascinated me as a collector of rare
weapons
kirowan familiar with my passion showed
only polite interest
but the effect on gordon was shocking
with a strangled cry he sprang up and
backward
knocking the chair clattering to the
floor fists clenched and countenance
livid he faced me crying
keep back get away from mirror i was
frozen in my tracks
one in the i began bewilderedly when
gordon with another amazing change of
attitude
dropped into a chair and sang his head
into his hands i saw his heavy shoulders
quiver
i stared helplessly from him to kirawan
who seemed equally dumbfounded
is he drunk i asked kirawan shook his
head and filling a brandy glass offered
it to the man
gordon looked up with haggard eyes
seized the drink and gulped it down like
a man half famished
then he straightened up and looked at us
shame-facedly
i'm sorry i went off the handle
o'donnell he said it was the unexpected
shock of you drawing that knife
well i retorted with some disgust i
suppose you thought i was going to stab
you with it
yes i did then at the utterly blank
expression on my face he added
oh i didn't actually think that at least
i didn't reach that conclusion by any
process of reasoning
it was just the blind primitive instinct
of a hunted man against whom anyone's
hand may be turned
his strange words in the despairing way
he said them sent a queer shiver of
nameless apprehension down my spine
what are you talking about i demanded
uneasily hunted for what
you never committed a crime in your life
not in this life perhaps
he muttered what do you mean
what if retribution for a crime
committed in a previous life were
hounding me
he said that's nonsense i snorted
oh is it he exclaimed stung did you ever
hear of my great-grandfather
sir richard gordon of argyll sure but
what's that got to do with
you've seen his portrait doesn't it
resemble me well
yes i admitted except that your
expression is frank and wholesome
whereas his is crafty and cruel he
murdered his wife
answered gordon suppose the theory of
reincarnation were true
why shouldn't a man suffer in one life
for a crime committed in another
you mean you think you are the
reincarnation of your great-grandfather
of all the fantastic well since he
killed his wife i suppose you'll be
expecting evelyn to murder you
this last was delivered in searing
sarcasm as i thought of the sweet gentle
girl gordon had married
his answer stunned me my wife he said
slowly has tried to kill me three times
in the past week
there was no reply to that i glanced
helplessly at john kiriwan
he sat in his customary position chin
resting on his strong slim
hands his white face was immobile but
his dark eyes gleamed with interest
in the silence i heard a clock ticking
like a death watch
tell us the full story gordon suggested
kirawan and his calm even voice was like
a knife that cut a strangling relieving
the unreal tension
you know we've been married less than a
year gordon began
plunging into the tail as though he were
bursting for utterance
his words stumbled and tripped over one
another all couples have spats of course
but we've never had any real quarrels
evelyn is the best-natured girl in the
world the first thing out of the
ordinary occurred about a week ago
we had driven up in the mountains left
the car and we were wandering around
picking wildflowers
at last we came to a steep slope some 30
feet in height
and evelyn called my attention to the
flowers which grew thickly at the foot
i was looking over the edge and
wondering if i could climb down without
tearing my clothes to ribbons
when i felt a violent shove from behind
that toppled me over
if it had been a sheer cliff i'd have
broken my neck as it was i went tumbling
down
rolling and sliding and brought up at
the bottom scratched and bruised with my
garments and rags
i looked up and saw evelyn staring down
apparently frightened half out of her
wits
oh jim she cried are you hurt how came
you to fall
it was on the tip of my tongue to tell
her that there was such a thing as
carrying a joke too far
but these words checked me i decided
that she must have stumbled against me
unintentionally and actually didn't know
it was she who precipitated me down the
slope
so i laughed it off and went home she
made a great fuss over me
insisted on swabbing my scratches with
iodine and lectured me for my
carelessness
i hadn't the heart to tell her it was
her fault but four days later the next
thing happened
i was walking along our driveway when i
saw her coming up it in the automobile
i stepped out on the grass to let her by
as there isn't any curb along the
driveway
she was smiling as she approached me and
slowed down the car as if to speak to me
then just before she reached me a most
horrible change came over her expression
without warning the car leaped at me
like a living thing as she drove her
foot down on the accelerator
only a frantic leap backward saved me
from being ground under the wheels
the car shot across the lawn and crashed
into a tree
i ran to it and found evelyn dazed and
hysterical but unhurt
she babbled of losing control of the
machine
i carried her into the house and sent
for dr donnelly
he found nothing seriously wrong with
her and attributed her dazed condition
to fright and shock
within half an hour she regained her
normal senses but she's refused to touch
the wheel since
strange to say she seemed less
frightened on her own account than on
mine
she seemed vaguely to know that she'd
nearly run me down
and grew hysterical again when she spoke
of it yet she seemed to take it for
granted that i knew the machine had got
out of her control
but i distinctly saw her wrench the
wheel around and i know
she deliberately tried to hit me why god
alone
knows still i refuse to let my mind
follow the channel it was getting into
evelyn had never given any evidence of
any psychological weakness or nerves
she's always been a level-headed girl
wholesome and natural
but i began to think she was subject to
crazy impulses
most of us have felt the impulse to leap
from tall buildings
and sometimes a person feels a blind
childish and utterly reasonless urge to
harm someone
we pick up a pistol and the thought
suddenly enters our mind how easy it
would be
to send our friend who sits smiling and
unaware into eternity with the touch of
a trigger
of course we don't do it but the impulse
is there so i thought perhaps some lack
of mental discipline made evelyn
susceptible to these unguided impulses
and unable to control them nonsense
i broke in i've known her since she was
a baby if she has any such trait she's
developed it since she married you
it was an unfortunate remark gordon
caught it up with a despairing gleam in
his eyes
that's just it since she married me it's
a curse
a black ghastly curse crawling like a
serpent out of the past
i tell you i was richard gordon and she
she was lady elizabeth his murdered wife
his voice sank to a blood-freezing
whisper
i shuddered it is an awful thing to look
upon the ruin of a keen clean brain
and such i was certain that i surveyed
in james gordon
why or how or by what grisly chance it
had come about
i could not say but i was certain the
man was mad
you spoke of three attempts it was john
kirawan's voice again
calm and stable amid the gathering webs
of horror and unreality
look here gordon lifted his arm drew
back the sleeve and displayed a bandage
the cryptic significance of which was
intolerable
i came into the bathroom this morning
looking for my razor he said
i found evelyn just on the point of
using my best shaving implement for some
feminine purpose
to cut out a pattern or something like
many women she can't seem to realize the
difference between a razor and a butcher
knife and a pair of sheers
i was a bit irritated and i said evelyn
how many times have i told you not to
use my razors for such things
bring it here i'll give you my pocket
knife i'm sorry jim
she said i didn't know it would hurt the
razor here it is
she was advancing holding the open razor
toward me
i reached for it then something warned
me it was the same look in her eyes
just as i had seen the day she nearly
ran over me that was all that saved my
life
for i instinctively threw up my hand
just as she slashed at my throat with
all her power
the blade gashed my arm as you see
before i caught her wrist
for an instant she fought me like a wild
thing her slender body was taught as
steel beneath my hands
then she went limp and the look in her
eyes was replaced by a strange dazed
expression
the razor slipped out of her fingers i
let go of her and she stood
swaying as if about to faint i went to
the lavatory
my wound was bleeding in a beastly
fashion and the next thing i heard her
cry out
and she was hovering over me jim she
cried
how did you cut yourself so terribly
gordon shook his head inside heavily
i guess i was a bit out of my head my
self-control snapped
don't keep up this pretense evelyn i
said god knows what's got into you
but you know as well as i that you've
tried to kill me three times in the past
week
she recoiled as if i'd struck her
catching at her breast and staring at me
as if it a ghost
she didn't say a word and just what i
said i don't remember
but when i finished i left her standing
there white and still as a marble statue
i got my arm bandaged at a drugstore and
then came over here
not knowing what else to do kiriwan
o'donnell
it's damnable either my wife is subject
to fits of insanity
he choked on the word no i can't believe
it
ordinarily her eyes are too clear and
level too utterly sane
but every time she has an opportunity to
harm me she seems to become a temporary
maniac
he beat his fists together in his
impotence and agony
but it isn't insanity i used to work in
a psychopathic ward
and i've seen every form of mental
imbalance my wife is not insane
then what i began but he turned haggard
eyes on me
only one alternative remains he answered
it is the old curse
from the days when i walked the earth
with a heart as black as hell's darkest
pits
and did evil in the sight of man and of
god she knows
in fleeting snatches of memory people
have seen before
have glimpsed forbidden things and
momentary liftings of the veil
which bars life from life she was
elizabeth douglas
the ill-fated bride of richard gordon
whom he murdered in jealous frenzy
and the vengeance is hers i shall die by
her hands
as it was meant to be and she he bowed
his head in his hands
just a moment it was kirawan again you
have mentioned a strange look in your
wife's eyes
what sort of a look was it of maniacal
frenzy
gordon shook his head it was an utter
blankness
although life and intelligence simply
vanished leaving her eyes dark wells of
emptiness
kirawan nodded and asked a seemingly
irrelevant question
have you any enemies not that i know of
you forget joseph rolock i said i can't
imagine that elegant sophisticate going
to the trouble of doing you actual harm
but i have an idea that if he could
discomfort you without any physical
effort on his part
he'd do it with a right good will
kiriwan turned on me an eye that
suddenly became piercing
and who is this joseph rolock a young
exquisite who came into evelyn's life
and nearly rushed her off her feet for a
while
but in the end she came back to her
first love gordon here
roloff took it pretty hard for all his
suaveness there's a streak of violence
and passion in the man
that might have cropped out but for his
infernal indolence and blase
indifference
oh there's nothing to be said against
rholock interrupted gordon impatiently
he must know that evelyn never really
loved him he merely fascinated her
temporarily with his romantic heir
well what is roelock to do with this
matter gordon snarled with the
irascibility of frayed nerves
he's been as friendly as a man could be
since evelyn and i were married
in fact only a week ago he sent her a
ring which he said was a peace offering
and a belated wedding gift said that
after all her jilting him was a greater
misfortune for her than it was for him
the conceited jackass a ring
kiriwan had suddenly come to life it was
as if something hard and steely had been
sounded in him
what sort of a ring oh a fantastic thing
copper made like a scaly snake coiled
three times
with its tail in its mouth and yellow
jewels for eyes
i gather he picked it up somewhere in
hungary
he's traveled a great deal in hungary
gordon looked surprised at this
questioning but answered
well apparently the man's traveled
everywhere i put him down as the
pampered son of a millionaire
he never did any work so far as i know
he's a great student i put in i've been
up to his apartment several times and i
never saw such a collection of books
gordon leaped to his feet with an oath
are we all crazy
he cried i came up here hoping to get
some help and you fellows follow the
talking of joseph roloff
i'll go to dr donnelly wait
kiran stretched out a detaining hand if
you don't mind we'll go over to your
house
i'd like to talk to your wife gordon
dumbly acquiesced
harried and haunted by grisly
forebodings he knew not which way to
turn
and welcomed anything that promised aid
we drove over in his car and scarcely a
word was spoken on the way
gordon was sunk in moody ruminations and
kiriwan had withdrawn himself into some
strange
aloof domain of thought beyond my ken he
sat like a statue
his dark vital eyes staring into space
not blankly
but is one who looks with understanding
into some far realm
though i counted the man as my best
friend i knew but little of his past
he had come into my life as abruptly and
unannounced as joseph roloff had come
into the life of evelyn ash
i had met him at the wanderers club
which is composed of the drift of the
world
travelers eccentrics and all manner of
men whose paths lie outside the beaten
tracks of life
i had been attracted to him and
intrigued by his strange powers and deep
knowledge
i vaguely knew that he was the black
sheep younger son of a titled irish
family
and that he had walked many strange ways
gordon's mention of hungary struck a
chord in my memory
one phase of his life kiriwan had once
let drop fragmentarily
i only knew that he had once suffered a
bitter grief and a savage wrong
and that it had been in hungary but the
nature of the episode i did not know
at gordon's house evelyn met us calmly
showing inner agitation only by the
over-restraint of her manner
i saw the besieging look she stole at
her husband
she was a slender soft-spoken girl whose
dark eyes were always vibrant and alight
with emotion
that child tried to murder her adored
husband the idea was monstrous
again i was convinced that james gordon
himself was deranged
following kirawan's lead we made a
pretense of small talk as if we had
casually dropped in
but i felt that evelyn was not deceived
our conversation rang false and hollow
and presently kirawan said mrs gordon
that is a remarkable ring you were
wearing do you mind if i look at it
i'll have to give you my hand she
laughed i've been trying to get it off
today and it won't come off
she held out her slim white hand for
kiriwan's inspection
and his voice was immobile as he looked
at the metal snake that coiled about her
slim
finger he did not touch it i myself was
aware of an unaccountable repulsion
there was something almost obscene about
that dull copperish reptile wound about
the girl's white finger
it's evil looking isn't it she
involuntarily shivered
at first i liked it but now i can hardly
bear to look at it
if i can get it off i intend to return
it to joseph mr rolok
kirowan was about to make some reply
when the doorbell rang
gordon jumped as if shot and evelyn rose
quickly
i'll answer it jim i know who it is she
returned an instant later with two more
mutual friends
those inseparable cronies dr donnelly
whose burly body jovial manner and
booming voice were combined with his key
in a brain as any in the profession
and bill bain elderly lean wiry acidly
witty
both were old friends of the ash family
dr donnelly had ushered evelynn into the
world
and bane was always uncle bill to her
howdy jim howdy mr kirowan
roared donnelly hey o'donnell have you
got any firearms with you
last time you nearly blew my head off
showing me an old flintlock pistol that
wasn't supposed to be loaded
dr donnelly we all turned
evelyn was standing beside a wide table
holding it as if for support
her face was white our baddinage ceased
instantly
a sudden tension was in the air dr
donnelly
she repeated holding her voice steady by
an effort
i sent for you and uncle bill for the
same reason for which i know jim has
brought mr carowan and michael
there is a matter gemiini can no longer
deal with alone
there is something between us something
black and ghastly and terrible
what are you talking about girl all the
levity was gone from donnelly's great
voice
my husband she choked then went blindly
on
my husband has accused me of trying to
murder him
the silence that fell was broken by
bane's sudden and energetic rise
his eyes blazed and his fists quivered
you young pup
he shattered at gordon i'll knock the
living daylights
sit down bill donnelly's huge hand
crushed his smaller companion back into
his chair
no use going off half cocked go ahead
honey
we need help we cannot carry this thing
alone
a shadow crossed her comely face this
morning jim's arm was badly cut
he said i did it i don't know i was
handing him the razor that i must have
fainted
at least everything faded away when i
came to myself he was washing his arm in
the lavatory
and he accused me of trying to kill him
why the young fool
barked the belligerent bane has any
sense enough to know that if you did cut
him it was an accident
shut up won't you snorted donnelly honey
did you say you fainted that doesn't
like you
i've been having fainting spells she
answered the first time was when we were
in the mountains and jim fell down a
cliff
we were standing on the edge then
everything went black and when my sight
cleared he was rolling down the slope
she shuddered at the recollection then
when i lost control of the car and it
crashed into the tree
you remember jim called you over dr
donnelly nodded his head ponderously
i don't remember you ever having
fainting spells before
but jim says i pushed him over the cliff
she cried hysterically
he says i tried to run him down in the
car he says i purposely slashed him with
the razor
dr donnelly turned perplexedly toward
the wretched gordon
how about it son god help me gordon
burst out in agony it's true
you lying hound it was bane who gave
tongue leaping again
to his feet if you want a divorce why
don't you get it in a decent way instead
of resorting to these despicable tactics
damn you rord gordon lunging up and
losing control of himself completely
if you say that i'll tear your jugular
out evelyn screamed
donnelly grabbed bane ponderously and
banged him back into his chair with no
overly gentle touch
and kirawan laid a hand lightly on
gordon's shoulder
the man seemed to crumple into himself
he sank back into his chair and held at
his hands
gropingly toward his wife evelyn
he said his voice thick with laboring
emotion you know i love you
i feel like a dog but god help me it's
true if we go on this way i'll be a dead
man
and you don't say it she screamed i know
you wouldn't lie to me jim
if you say i tried to kill you i know i
did but i swear jim i didn't do it
consciously
i must be going mad that's why my dreams
have been so wild and terrifying lately
of what have you dreamed mrs gordon
asked kirawan gently
she pressed her hands to her temples and
stared dully at him as if only half
comprehending
a black thing she muttered a horrible
faceless black thing that mows and
mumbles and paws over me with apis hands
i dream of it every night and in the
daytime i try to kill the only man i
ever loved
i'm going mad maybe i'm already crazy
and don't know it
calm yourself honey to dr donnelly with
all his science
it was only another case of feminine
hysteria his matter-of-fact voice seemed
to soothe her
and she sighed and drew a weary hand
through her damp locks
we'll talk this all over and
everything's going to be okay he said
drawing a thick cigar from his vest
pocket give me a match honey
she began mechanically to feel about the
table and just as mechanically gordon
said
there are matches in the drawer evelyn
she opened the drawer and began groping
in it
when suddenly as if struck by
recollection and intuition
gordon sprang up white-faced and shouted
no
don't open that drawer don't even as he
voiced that urgent cry she stiffened as
if at the feel of something in the
drawer
her change of expression held us all
frozen even chiron
the vital intelligence vanished from her
eyes like a blown-out flame
and into them came the look gordon had
described as blank
the term was descriptive her beautiful
eyes were dark wells of emptiness
as if the soul had been withdrawn from
behind them
her hand came out of the drawer holding
a pistol and she fired point blank
gordon reeled with a groan and went down
blood starting from his head
for a flashing instant she looked down
stupidly at the smoking gun in her hand
like one suddenly waking from a
nightmare then her wild scream of agony
smote our ears
oh god i've killed him jim jim
she reached him before any of us
throwing herself on her knees and
cradling his bloody head in her arms
while she sobbed in an unbearable
passion of horror and anguish
the emptiness was gone from her eyes
they were alive and dilated with grief
and terror
i was making toward my prostrate friend
with donnelly and bane
but kirawan caught my arm his face was
no longer immobile
his eyes glittered with a controlled
savagery
leave him to them he snarled we are
hunters not healers
lead me to the house of joseph rolok i
did not question him
we drove there in gordon's car i had the
wheel
and something about the grim face of my
companion caused me to hurl the machine
recklessly through the traffic
i had the sensation of being part of a
tragic drama which was hurtling with
headlong
speed toward a terrible climax i
wrenched the car to a grinding halt at
the curb before the building where
roloch lived
in a bizarre apartment high above the
city the very elevator that shot us
skyward seemed imbued with something of
kiriwan's driving urge for haste
i pointed out rollock's door and he cast
it open without knocking and shouldered
his way in
i was close at his heels rholoch
in a dressing gown of chinese silk
worked with dragons
was lounging on a divan puffing quickly
at a cigarette
he sat up overturning a wine glass which
stood with a half-filled bottle at his
elbow
before akirawan could speak i burst out
with our news
james gordon has been shot he sprang to
his feet
shot when when did she kill him
she i glared and bewilderment how did
you know
with a steely hand kiriwan thrust me
aside and as the men
faced each other i saw recognition flare
up in rolox's face
they made a strong contrast kiriwan tall
pale with some white hot passion roloff
slim
darkly handsome with the saracenic arch
of his slim brows above his black eyes i
realized that whatever else occurred it
lay between those two men
they were not strangers i could sense
like a tangible thing the hate that lay
between them
john kiriwan softly whispered roloch
you remember me yosef rolok only in iron
control kept kirawan's voice steady
the other merely stared at him without
speaking
years ago said kiriwan more deliberately
when we delved into the dark mysteries
together in budapest
i saw where you were drifting i drew
back
i would not descend to the foul depths
of forbidden occultism and diabolism to
which you sank
and because i would not you despised me
and you robbed me of the only woman i
ever loved
you turned her against me by means of
your vile arts and then you degraded and
debauched her
sank her into your own foul slime i had
killed you with my own hands then
yosef vrollock vampire by nature as well
as by name that you are
but your arts protected you from
physical vengeance
but you have trapped yourself at last
kirawan's voice rose in fierce
exaltation
all his cultured restraint had been
swept away from him leaving a primitive
elemental man
raging and gloating over a hated foe you
sought the destruction of james gordon
and his wife
because she unwittingly escaped your
snare
rolock shrugged his shoulders and
laughed you were mad
i've not seen the gordons for weeks why
blame me for their family troubles
kiriwan snarled liar as always what did
you say just now when o'donnell told you
gordon had been shot
when did she kill him you were expecting
to hear that the girl had killed her
husband
your psychic powers had told you that a
climax was close at hand
you were nervously awaiting news of the
success of your devilish scheme
but i did not need a slip of your tongue
to recognize your handiwork
i knew as soon as i saw the ring on
evelyn gordon's finger
the ring she could not remove the
ancient and accursed ring of thoth ammon
handed down by foul cults of sorcerers
since the days of forgotten stygia
i knew that ring was yours and i knew by
what ghastly rites you came to possess
it
and i knew its power once she put it on
her finger
in her innocence and ignorance she was
in your power
by your black magic you summon the black
elemental spirit
the haunter of the ring out of the gulfs
of night and the ages
here in your accursed chamber you
performed unspeakable rituals
to drive evelyn gordon's soul from her
body and to cause that body to be
possessed by that godless sprite from
outside the human universe
she was too clean and wholesome her love
for her husband too strong
for the fiend to gain complete and
permanent possession of her body
only for brief instance could it drive
her own spirit into the void and animate
her form
but that was enough for your purpose but
you brought ruin upon yourself by your
vengeance
kirawan's voice rose to a feline screech
what was the price demanded by the fiend
you drew from the pits
ha you blanch joseph frolock is not the
only man to have learned forbidden
secrets
after i left hungary a broken man i took
up again the study of the black arts
to trap you you cringing serpent i
explored the ruins of zimbabwe the lost
mountains of inner mongolia and the
forgotten jungle islands of the southern
seas
i learned what sickened my soul so that
i foreswore occultism forever
but i learned of the black spirit that
deals death by the hand of a beloved one
and is controlled by a master of magic
but yosef rolok you were not an adept
you have not the power to control the
fiend you have invoked and you have sold
your soul
the hungarian tore at his collar as if
it were a strangling noose
his face had changed as if a mask had
dropped away
he looked much older you lie he panted
i did not promise him my soul i do not
lie
kirawan's shriek was shocking in its
wild exaltation
i know the price a man must pay for
calling forth in nameless shape that
roams the gulfs of darkness
look there in the corner behind you a
nameless sightless thing is laughing
is mocking you it has fulfilled its
bargain and it has come for you
joseph vrolock no no shrieked vrolock
tearing his limp collar away from his
sweating throat his composure had
crumpled and his demoralization was
sickening to see
i tell you it was not my soul i promised
it a soul but not my soul
he must take the soul of the girl or of
james gordon
fool roared kiriwan do you think he
could take the souls of innocents
that he would not know they were beyond
his reach the girl and the youth he
could kill
their souls were not his to take or
yours to give
but your black soul is not beyond his
reach and he will have his wage
look he is materializing behind you he's
growing out of thin air
was it the hypnosis inspired by
kiriwan's burning words that caused me
to shudder and grow cold
to feel an icy chill that was not of
earth pervade the room
was it a trick of light and shadow that
seemed to produce the effect of a black
anthropomorphic shadow on the wall
behind the hungarian
no by heaven it grew it swelled froloch
had not turned
he stared at carowan with eyes starting
from his head hair standing stiffly on
his scalp
sweat dripping from his livid face
kirawan's cry
started shudders down my spine look
behind you i see him
he's come he's here his grisly mouth
gapes and awful laughter
his misshapen paws reach for you and
then at last vrolock wheeled with an
awful shriek
throwing his arms above his head in a
gesture of wild despair
and for one brain-shattering instant he
was blotted out by a great black shadow
kiriwan grasped my arm and we fled from
that accursed chamber
blind with horror the same paper which
bore a brief item telling of james
gordon having suffered a slight scalp
wound by the accidental discharge of a
pistol in his home
headlined the sudden death of joseph
roloff wealthy and eccentric
club man in his sumptuous apartments
apparently from heart failure
i read it at breakfast while i drank cup
after cup of black coffee
from a hand that was not too steady even
after the lapse of the night
across the table from me kiriwan
likewise seemed to lack appetite
he brooded as if he roamed again through
bygone years
gordon's fantastic theory of
reincarnation was wild enough
i said it last but the actual facts were
still more incredible tell me kiriwan
was that last seen the result of
hypnosis
was it the power of your words that made
me seem to see a black horror grow out
of the air
and rip yosef roloff's soul from his
living body
he shook his head no human hypnotism
would strike that black-hearted devil
dead on the floor
no there are beings outside the ken of
common humanity
foul shapes of trans-cosmic evil such a
one it was with which vrolock dealt
but how could it claim his soul i
persisted if indeed such an awful
bargain had been struck
it had not fulfilled its part for james
gordon was not dead
but merely knocked senseless frolock did
not know it
answered kiriwan he thought that gordon
was dead and i convinced him that he
himself had been trapped and was doomed
in his demoralization he fell easy prey
to the thing he called forth
it of course was always watching for a
moment of weakness on his part
the powers of darkness never deal fairly
with human beings
he who trafficks with them is always
cheated in the end
it's a mad nightmare i muttered but it
seems to me then that you as much as
anything else brought about froloch's
death
it is gratifying to think so kiriwan
answered
evelyn gordon is safe now and it is a
small repayment for what he did to
another girl
years ago and in a far country
you